hi my name is Jim regard together with
patrick akan burg i will present the
Wolfram system over in education it's
based on some intern projects we have
this summer we're interns were
developing a material for education in
system modeler and we will present
different examples from that
so let's get started my name is Jurgen
and I'm here to present together with
Patrick Eichenberg over there we're
presenting a work on how to use system
over in education and it's based on
works that three we had three interns at
the office during this summer do recent
work so was free Desmond Sun she's a
master students in Applied Physics and
electrical engineering
it's Anna Palmer from Australia who has
a Bachelor in biomedicine and yes
starting her master's and then a male
artist Oh from Sweden that is studying
biological engineering masters there's
two so during this summer we hadn't come
to mathcore our office inland shopping
and gave them a crash course of about
three days in system modeler and then we
basically gave them an open sheet where
they could choose any topic they would
like to I thought this is something I
studied in back at the University that
thought was a little bit complicated
that to understand or at high school
that I thought was complicated to
understand and that could be improved by
using models so basically well Emil was
at Wolfram ethical last year so he had
some experience the two others were
completely new to the product and now
we're presenting a bit of what they've
done and so you can see and get some
kind of inspiration on how to use it so
the material that has been developed to
give a quick overview is some material
for for primary and high schools and
some material for colleges and
universities
the idea is to expand on this as we go
so if we start looking at at the primary
high schools we have some material for
physics with examples like hitting a
baseball jumping on a trampoline doing a
banjee jump I will use the bungee jump
example to illustrate
a bit how it's actually used the ideas
of how to use it for teaching and then
within life science we Anna Palmer
developed models for population dynamics
studying things like the spread of
malaria and Patrick will show that later
on for colleges and universities last
year we presented this one so a few of
you probably saw that where we're
looking at classical mechanics and how
to how to make that more understandable
by use of models so we could basically
make a model of a swing and and simulate
and understand more of it there's also
some exercises in computational biology
and I actually don't have no clue what
what this what this model is about but
one of the examples electrical
engineering we presented at last year so
it's not going to be presented this year
and finally some on chemistry and
Patrick is going to present the
chemistry part so as you can see it's
material from a kind of wide range of
applications that we have been working
on together we are with our interns and
and I will start with with the physics
and okay this was small it's like that
okay so each of these materials were
been working on have four different
pieces to it
there are teacher instructions and we'll
look at them soon how they look like
so basically given the background to the
teacher about the example there are the
assignments to the students with the
model and quest appropriate questions
for the student the corresponding models
to be used as well as the solutions so
all these are developed for each of
these let's say pieces of courseware
so let's look at at the part here with
physics what Frieda worked on during the
summer and and the idea was to make
examples that are playful and fun so
basically she said that when she was
studying back in high school she had a
lot of classmates that didn't like
physics they didn't like math and for
that reason they didn't really get
engaged and and didn't learn too much so
said like but if we could do that more
like come alive then perhaps those kids
would start to like and understand the
physics better so that was her ambition
with it making making them be able to do
rather complicated things without having
to go into the tricky for most behind
the scenes and so things she took
inspiration for from two courses that
she had been taking physics one two
three from the Swedish upper secondary
school and also engineering mechanics
that Jesus had been taking at the
University so these two were kind of
basic input for her there and then
should use some books which you also
refer to in the material as background
so they actually relate to what you are
teaching in the specific courses okay so
she worked with four different different
examples one bungee-jump I will go into
this soon so I am NOT talking more G but
then a bit about trains one on
trampoline and one on baseball so if we
look at the one on baseball the type of
questions should try to answer is are
there any baseball fans here I guess
there is anyone yeah one two three
some even if I would ask in Sweden
nobody would
so apparently there's someone called
Yogi Berra they kind of know and he said
you can't think and hit at the same time
it goes too fast so the ambition when
when Freda developed this was well what
if we could do this so you can kind of
hit it and think at the same time
because if you simulate you can pause it
and you can kind of see and study
different parts of it and start to
understand the physics and dynamics of
how to hit the ball there's still some
fine-tuning on this exercise so I'm have
opted not to show that today but it's
it's going to be really good actually so
let's look at one of those that is more
finished finished is a bungee jump and
some of you might have seen this example
because it's available for download or a
version of this available for download
at our web page and where I've done some
or freedom made some modifications to it
she took this and first of all she said
some okay what's the learning objectives
that this could relate to so one of the
things you're studying is gravitation
effects on falling bodies you are
supposed to learn how to explore
different parameters and initial values
how they affect some dynamics of a
system how the stiffness work how how
what is frequency what happens with
frequency if you if you add increase in
mass or jump faster or whatever you do
in the jump so those personal questions
is what the students are supposed to
learn about and then of course that's
what Frieda tries to address with the
example so let's let's take a look at it
so this is a model it's a it looks kind
of simple we have a platform those that
are or have been in Australia kind of
recognize the platform we have a cord
and a jumper the jumper is 20 75 kilos
and we have a a cord with some
specifications what the student can do
here in house instructions is how to do
is they can simulate that and open up
the it's small like that so they
simulate this and they will get some
results out from it the cord is kind of
advanced the model so it takes a bit to
simulate there we go so what what we're
seeing here is the height of the jumper
as we were jumping so we have start at
10 meters and it takes a jump out and
then kind of oscillates up and down so
it gives an idea how it works but they
can also look at the animation of it
there you go so we'll have the jumper
here standing on the how many here ever
however have done a bungee jump
no one oh me neither actually I would
like to but I've never done it so so
we're taking jump here and in this case
the cord you might see that the core is
is like not exactly like a real court
would look like and that's part of the
exercise it's showing you how different
types of models might affect the results
you start to understand the difference
between like reality and a model so if
we look at this I can trace the path of
it jumper like that and let's jump again
so now he's sorry jumping there and we
can follow the path or jumping we can
also see that together with with a plot
so if I do like this will be a bit small
now but you will see the line showing
where we are so if we want to see the
exact value of actually any given thing
in the model at any given point of time
we can do that okay so this means that
now the student has something to engage
in and that might be kind of fun to play
around with so what could I do then if
they have this well let's look at type
of questions that you could have and I'm
not going through all of them there and
there's more questions in the in the
assignments but there are things like
which scenario might put the jumper into
risk so how do you assess that this is a
safe thing to do localized turning
points when the jumper bounces up and
towards the platform again how can you
find this at what time does the jumper
hit the water in
three scenarios so obviously worse three
scenarios before them we need to try it
hate the work so those type of questions
some of them that has a specific answer
and others that are more about
discussion getting the the concepts and
ideas of physics and if we look at the
material then let's open the teacher
instructions the teacher instructions
come with things first it gives the
teacher what kind of background do you
need which would software's do you need
to download how do how is the setup and
and a lot of details about the model
that typically the student won't really
see but it's good for the for the
teacher to have that background
knowledge and then it gives also let's
do this that it gives things like
further suggestions once you've done
this you can do these for that and it
gives the model assumptions that you had
made and so on so it gives the teacher
the background needed in order to to be
teaching this specific course okay and
then they have solutions I'm not going
to go through the solutions too much but
I just want to show which in which form
they are so the solutions are not only
like a number saying this is the answer
the telling the idea about how to
actually do come up with a solution and
it says for instance here we can look at
in this section the student will
practice reading and interpreting plots
the student does not have access to all
different for most as the purpose of the
exercise is to only read the plot and
learn how to get values from it so it's
a very basic example while other other
examples might require more knowledge
about equations and so on there are in
all sorts of levels
and then finally what they also have the
models you already seen then of course
you have the student assignments the
students assignments have the learning
objectives they have the reading
material and then they gives tip step by
step instructions on how to do it just
like hello this model load this package
this is how it looks like and eventually
you will get to your first give some
background and get your first question
and so on so this material you should be
able to take it and yes do the exercises
without having to any any previous
knowledge about system modeler or
Mathematica by the way it should kind of
just work that's the idea and remember
they're the the students that did this
they had three day crash course before
before they did the material so yeah
it's that's the sort of things that are
involved here so okay so how do you do
them now to answer these questions so we
saw the model one simulation of it and
one question was how deep or how heavy
can a jumper be before he hits the
ground so then what the student can do
is it can start off play around with the
mass and say let's have the jumper be 90
kilos simulate again and see what
happens and I don't think 90 kilos is
enough if I remember correctly but
anyway see he will get closer
so jumps down here hey sorry you can't
even see him but and didn't hit the
ground but but still you can start to
play around change values until you
found exactly the value needed to hit
the water and then of course this unity
is needs kind of explain what that
happens and so on but you can also go
take it to the next level so suppose
that you would like to invent a new
version of bungee jump where you don't
only have one jumper and don't know have
one cord you had two jumpers and two
courts or as many as you want then you
can prepare the model so you can do
things like this a change component type
and here we have another type of bungee
cord which is called multi jump let's
pull that here and the graphic changes
it says now that we're two jumpers so
let's look at that what will happen if
two people were jumping at the same time
and not in parallel there are like a
suit so there we go
and of course if they want to add a
third jump or whatever they can do that
and now is that's we think is the time
when you start to really engage and play
around okay what's happening here what's
doing here and that's kind of the idea
with all this material and with that
I'll leave my part and Patrick will
continue with population dynamics I
think the first one right so as John
mentioned I'll go a few more of these
applications areas where we asked the
some interns where they felt like models
would really enhance certain concepts
and I'd like to start out with the work
done by Anna Palmer so we asked her when
she started out is there any courses
that she that she had taken while in
high school where she felt like she
wanted to have a model that she could
play around with
and really understand what is happening
behind the scenes and one of the first
things that she came up with was
population dynamics now what is
population dynamics and population
genetics you might ask well in a broad
sense you could say it it's used to
explain all the life around this is used
to explain why for example this tree
here as in leaves or why why giraffes
have long necks or why birds can fly but
that's a bit fluffy so I'll break it
down a bit
population genetics concerns how genes
that is which defines your different
types of traits how they seem to change
in populations of generations why some
traits seem to grow more common as time
goes by and while other traits they die
out it's also used to explain for
example why the species we see around us
today look very much different from how
we believe that their ancestors looked a
long time ago as so that's kind of the
fundamental concepts of that and it's
also used for example to explain why I
have brown eyes or why John here has
blue eyes and the way we kind of usually
teach this is by first we're looking at
individual inheritance
well we're explaining how your parents
give down your their genes their traits
down to you their offspring and we're
also explaining it by looking at the
world how it looks today we're looking
at well we're looking at the saying that
the giraffes for example they have long
necks because they are fit in an
environment where the trees are long so
they can reach the food up there but one
thing that Ana felt that she didn't
quite
get a grasp of by using this but when
she was taught these concepts was how
things change over time because by just
looking at today we're not explaining
all the small gradual changes in traits
that led us to where we are today where
life is today and by extension where she
didn't get a grasp of how things would
change for tomorrow and in a world where
the environment you know it's constantly
changing the these questions are more
more important now for the students than
ever to understand and also she felt
that by just looking by just
understanding how her parents passed
down their traits down to her just on an
individual level she didn't get the
whole concept of what actually happening
happening in real life with whole
populations that mix together and form
complex dynamics and what she felt was
that she could if she could have a model
where she could tune this these
different things that she could to track
how the traits changed during
generations then she would understand
that better so what she went ahead and
did was she created a whole modeling
library where she could set up
population groups and understand how the
traits of those population groups
changed over time and remember she as
John mentioned she did this with only a
three-day crash course in system older
so this is pretty impressive so what
this is a very simple model that's
developed using her library and I'll
zoom in a bit so you can see it better
oh that's maybe a bit too much
so here we have four different
population groups that that's what kind
of this describes and two of them have
one set of genes that we call it trait a
here and the other ones they have
another set of genes we call it trait to
be and in those population groups they
can either be young enough to not be
well they're not mature enough yet to
reproduce so they're not affecting how
many new organisms are born into each
each of the groups but from here they
have two different alternatives some
which are not adapted to the environment
and might die before they are mature
enough for reproduction while others of
this be the species might end up here
and here where they are here they will
affect the number of newborns which are
added to their population groups so it's
kind of a feedback loop of sorts that's
happening here and so we can kind of
look at how now that we have a model
here we can take a few of the parameters
from these one this model tweaked them
around a bit to understand what is
happening in populations so since we
have since we've done this
we can open up a simulate we can run a
simulation from the ball from language
which I think will open up right now
hopefully yeah there we go
it's just loading it in so here we have
a trace of the populations over time
right now we are able to tweak a few
parameters here we can change which ones
how the trait distributions look at the
beginning of time and we can change how
many of a certain trait survive until
reproduction so we can see that with
just a small change the one of the
populations will go down if
not suited for the environment and this
might seem like a very simple model and
it is but still yes this one can be used
to explain a lot of the things that's
happening around us in real life and let
me give you a more concrete example of
this what we can explain with this with
this model and that is the case of the
peppered moths now in in pre-industrial
England a lot of the moths looked like
this they were white with some black
spots and the reason why they looked
like this was because that allowed them
to hide on the lichen covered tree
trunks and they were kind of camouflaged
against against the environment and the
predatory Birds for example they had a
hard time spotting them that meant that
more of those that look like more of the
moths that look like this would would
survive until reproduction than the
moths that look like this because there
were a few moths
that had those that were completely
black like this but they were easily
picked off by predatory birds now and
then the population let's see just
adjust this one up a bit see if my
computer wants to yeah so the population
of the of the black moths went down
pretty quickly now something happened
when during the industrial revolution
and the the all the coal that was
spewing out of the from the industries
they they killed off the lichen on the
trees and it's blackened the tree trunks
and maybe you can imagine what happened
then well of course it was much easier
for the black moths to hide against the
tree trunks so that oh that one
disappeared anyway
so they were more fit to the environment
and the graphs kind of look like this
now after just a few years of just a few
generations even though they were very
very uncommon before the Industrial
Revolution sometime after the black
moths were actually the most common
common species so that is one of the
things that we use to describe with this
model and let me give you I think I have
time for another example and that is the
case of malaria and sickle cell anemia
and this is something John showed the
assignment sheets previously so this is
something that are almost straight up
lifted from one of the assignments that
Ana has created and it aims to display
n-- malaria and sickle cell anemia and
what is there to explain you might ask
well malaria and sickle cell anemia
there are two completely different
diseases one of them is a genetic sickle
cell anemia it's a genetic disease
that's brought down from parents to
offspring while malaria is a disease
that comes from parasites that's
transmitted from mosquitoes in yet even
those even though these are completely
different I should say that what happens
with sickle cell anemia is that your red
blood your red blood cells that normally
look like this they start to form sickle
say shapes like this which is really bad
now anyway what happens in the sickle
cell anemia and malaria is that they are
present in the same areas and why would
that be and also yeah and why would that
be well to understand this we can use
one of the models that she had created
it's just just a bit bigger than the
previous one and here we introduced a
concept in generic which
a genetic carrier now you might know
that you have one set of genes form from
your mom and one set of genes from your
dad and in some cases these are
identical in some cases they differ and
that gives you different types of traits
and if you get if you have one healthy
gene on the for sickle cell anemia and
one that actually gives you sickle cell
anemia then you're still healthy you
needed to get one of those genes from
your dad and one of those genes from
your mom and that's when you actually
develop sickle cell anemia so here she
has introduced another population group
and the first one here are the healthy
ones they have two two healthy genes
rather against sickle cell anemia here
they have one healthy and one sick gene
and here they have 2/16 and sadly as you
can see here they we can almost assume
that they don't those to actually
develop sickle cell anemia they don't
survive until reproduction now one might
imagine that these from the previous
example you might imagine that this gene
would die off it doesn't infer any
benefit well actually it does
surprisingly seemingly it does in
malaria affected areas being a carrier
remember that doesn't if you're only a
carrier for sickle cell anemia that
doesn't make you sick
it actually infers a benefit inverse a
protection against malaria so what we
can do with this model is we can we can
simulate this and we can see what
happens so if I bring this one up and it
just needs to load it in a bit
okay and once again she has given us a
few parameters to tweak with there's a
lot of parameters in this model and you
can just bring out exactly the ones that
will you know explain the right concepts
to your students now what we can see
here is in an environment where we can
say that if there is malaria in this
environment or not in an environment
where malaria is not common then we as
we expect the number of carriers would
decline and the number of non carriers
would go up but in we can simulate this
in a malaria endemic country I think
then we'll see that the number of
carriers go up because it infers a
protection against malaria so these are
kind of the intuitions that we can make
the students get by playing along with
this themselves and we don't have to say
it beforehand that this is what they are
supposed to understand they will get
that intuition by exploring these models
so I kind of want to show how this can
look as we give it to a student it looks
kind of the things like the things that
John gave you that John showed you but a
bit different here we have the thing
that we give to the students
it contains the reading material but yah
they are they are as a system
description and then everything that
they are supposed to do is done in
inside of the notebook they get
everything he preloaded don't have to
understand and evolve from language code
if if it isn't a topic and we only don't
have to understand how to build these
models in system model we could just
give them an assignment notebook and say
hey play with this and then of course
answer answer the questions after each
check section so that's kind of how it
can can look and we making this more
simplified notebooks sometimes when
we're targeting high school students so
that they can just jump right into it we
don't have to assume that they know
anything really other than the topic
area so that was kind of a virtual lab
of sorts when I think of laboratory
exercises you know I come from a
different kind of area I come from a
biochemical engineering area so when I
think of laboratory exercises
I think of strapping on your lab coat
and the rubber gloves and the pipette in
hand and ready to explore the universe
so these are those physical labs and
this virtual lab that we had set up it's
it's a bit different but in reality they
are a lot similar in the goals that they
are trying to achieve and they both are
trying to give you theoretical knowledge
by giving you practical things to do by
engaging you and letting you play around
for yourself now we also thought about
with the could we bring it such a
real-life lab so those that I'm familiar
with can we bring that into a virtual
lab environment and more maybe more
importantly is there any reason why we
would want to do that and to give you
kind of a some motivate motivation for
this let me tell you a story about when
I was an undergraduate student we were
doing a laboratory exercise we were
supposed to understand if a bacteria I
can't remember exactly what was supposed
to understand if they were if we had a
certain bacteria in a sample or or
another type so what we did was we
placed it into these small
sample pipes and we put it in a
centrifuge it went round round round the
the bacteria fell to the bottom and it
kind of looked like this the bacteria
ends up in the bottom in something
that's called the pellet and then
everything around it ends up in the
fluid above it that's called the
supernatant now these are excruciatingly
ly often excruciatingly long exercises
and you get a stack of paper called a
lab manual that's details exactly what
you're supposed to do so we have gone
ahead there run six hours of or so
before we got got this sample and then I
knew from the lab manual that you were
supposed to have the bacteria for the
next step so I threw away the
supernatant the fluid thing on the top
and oh no because something that they
tell you when you're starting out with
for example chemistry biochemistry or
even cooking is that you should read the
recipe before and you should read the
lab manual completely beforehand and of
course it turns out that they're on page
12 / whatever it said that you needed
the supernatant for another step which
is quite bad because you know it wasn't
down in the drain so say from trying to
salvage it from the drain trap it was
just nowhere nowhere to be found anymore
and that meant of course that all the
six hours I spent before this preparing
this were wasted or were they wasted
because I don't think they were because
I learned something important there and
it wasn't that you should read the
recipe because I still don't do that
which is my word might be why I'm
working with computers rather than in a
laboratory anyway I learned why I need
the discipline eight and for the next
step because failing at something
made me much more interested in why we
did it I read up that oh well it doesn't
really matter but we needed it for the
next step and I understood why and I
probably wouldn't have done that if I
just follow it along in a laboratory
manual you know doing step by step I
wouldn't I don't remember the other
steps today for example but of course it
also meant that I couldn't complete the
rest of there to our lab because I
didn't have the material and one thing
in chemistry and biochemistry is that
material is really expensive so even if
they even if I could redo that
everything which probably didn't have
time to well we were limited by the by
the material cost so it would be nice if
I could you know be allowed to make the
mistakes that I did
be allowed to actually actually try
different things outside of the recipe
understanding why those those
instructions are there in the first
place and it would be nice if I could
have before I actually went out and did
that physical laboratory exercise if I
could be able to to run it in a
simulation and be able to make those
mistakes so and I kind of glossed over
him in the beginning I'm sorry ml but
iam in one of our summer interns it was
quite a thought along the same paths so
he thought well what if we could create
a chemical or a biochemical or any type
of laboratory exercise in a virtual
environment how would that look so he
went ahead and created some for the
separation of hemoglobin and now I'm
getting kind of a crossover between the
previous ones on
but hemoglobin is the things in your
cells that in your red blood cells that
binds to oxygen and distributed to the
rest of the body and sometimes we want
to take a sample of blood we want to
extract the red blood cells and extract
the hemoglobin from that and just have a
pure sample of that and why would we
want to do that well one of the reasons
actually is because it's an important
diagnostic tools for sickle-cell anemia
so this is purely an unintentional but
that if you take the pure sample of
hemoglobin you can see if if someone has
sickle cell anemia and one of the other
nice things about this process is that
it involves a lot of steps which I like
because then there's a lot of ways to
make mistakes to learn from so I kind of
want to show what what it did and this
time I'm not showing the model that's
running we have a model here that
describes everything that's happening in
the lab but I don't want to show that
here because that's not the topic and
this is something that we probably won't
show to the students either it's just a
vessel for it's just something for them
to interact with but they don't have to
understand what's happening behind the
scenes right anyway so what this kind of
wood could look like is we can start
start the simulation behind the scenes
hopefully yeah and then we have a couple
of different steps that a meal he took a
lab manual he lifted the steps right out
of them and he made it something he made
a simulation model for it and he made
interfaces for the students to interact
with so the first part of separating
these hemoglobin from the blood is the
centrifuge again centrifuged
in the samples so it made a virtual
centrifuge that the students can
interact with and there's a couple of
settings for the centrifuge here we're
just saying that how fast am number of
g's we should give it and then what it
would kind of look like in a lab you
would be able to set that those settings
you would be able to start the
centrifuge the lab manual would tell you
to wait five or so minutes and then you
would collect your samples now since
this is a simulation model we can
actually provide the students with a bit
more than that we can provide them with
an insight if we want to we can provide
them with an inside look of what is
happening within the within the vessel
so here we can see a trace with some
different some different concentrations
and here we're seeing the red blood
cells getting removed from the
supernatant sorry for the technical
jargon but it's getting it's forming
inside in a pellet in the bottom of the
of the vessel and we can stop the
centrifuge and we can we can see that
okay then they the concentration stays
the same in the in the kind of fluid
part we can also allow them to make to
make mistakes such as the lab protocol
will tell them to okay you're not you
can't you shouldn't centrifuge these
harder than 500 GS but what will happen
if we do that anyway we can allow them
to make mistakes well the as you will
see here the purple red broke I think
yeah the broken red blood cells will
start to increase because we are
breaking
we're actually breaking the cells and
then we can stop the centrifuge and we
can move on to the next step and the
next step it will be running on the same
state as they left left the other state
as that they left the other
the other step so if they made mistakes
there it will follow them along so then
there's some more you know interfaces
for them to interact with and they could
they could even jump jump ahead a step
see what happens okay I don't want to
wait for this centrifuge I could just I
just want to get a yellow get on with my
day what would happen then and of course
we can allow them to restart from
anywhere where so here we could allow
them to restart from the beginning they
make made a mistake we have we can give
them unlimited material because it's
just a simulation we can give them
unlimited time with with the laboratory
equipment which is kind of neat because
these usually arrange in the price tag
of ten to a hundred thousand dollars so
it's pretty neat to give each student
one of their own and of course then I'm
not going to go through all of these
steps but but then they would go through
and it will tell you them what what
they're doing in each step what to learn
from the steps what kind of mistakes
they are allowed to make this time
around so that's two other applications
areas where we could use system models
to explain different concepts right I
think that was all I had for for this
we're giving a few more talks this
conference this was the first of the
talks we're giving on Voltron system
modeler in different applications areas
in different ways tomorrow
John will be giving a talk of what's new
in the system of the five we released a
new version a major version now this
summer that comes with some exciting new
things among other things stuff that
we're using in these in these
educational scenarios also tomorrow I'll
give a talk on how we're trying to
further integrate sister muddler inside
the ball front language how we can think
a model of a system for example this
laboratory exercise the Bunge jump how
we can think of that as a symbol within
the vole firm language that you can
interact with in any way you want right
on on Friday
John will be giving a presentation
that's kind of like this one but looking
at system modular from an industry
perspective how we can use system
modeler to design different applications
before you actually for example build
them and if you want a sneak peak of
what's happening there you can come down
to our hardware lab in the basement
where we are displaying how we built a
model in system modular of something
that we then then went ahead and built
in real life and what kind of what kind
of understanding we could get from that
model before we went to help that had
been built the real thing so with that I
think I will I will end this
presentation if John doesn't have
anything to add oh yes sir
oh okay yeah so with that are the any
questions for me and for John no
questions well if you think of anything
or if your interaction I should say that
since we've developed these these course
words and we're looking to distribute
them to universities that are interested
in using them for education we would
love to get in touch with anyone that
would be interested in actually using
these models in their in their classroom
so just grab a hold of us after this
presentation if you if you're interested
in that or if there are any further
questions that you didn't dare to speak
up right now I see you're all terrified
yeah so with that I thank you for
listening
[Applause]